[Music]
Mulan me because you move immediately
when I said it so you grab my attention
okay
so you know like Mulan story is where
like she pretended to be a man she would
go out and fight anymore well there's
like this this one chick they're calling
her like the modern-day Mulan so her
name is Tatiana she's 22 years old and
she is a really tough female boxer in
Russia or from Russia and she has
admitted to lying about her gender in
order for her to fight men because they
were not letting her fight men so she
pretended to be a guy so she could fight
men why did she want to fight men for
her she's tired of hearing people say
that girls are weak I was like the WNBA
versus the real NBA something like this
would be an incredible real NBA this
would be a great story well this is a
great Super already but this is the
amazing story if she never won yeah it's
kind of like it's like not like other
girls but on steroids this is up that
she fought a guy prolly yeah like you
know this is when she's fighting but
then also oh wow pretending to be a dude
whoa she was pretending to be Vladimir
of course okay that's very dramatic okay
yeah and so they're saying that she won
I believe 9 out of 17 fights I think she
just wanted to beat men up that's what I
was asking like what's the intention we
said for wanting to fight guy yeah it's
not it's not a sexist thing it's a it's
a physiological thing yeah a lot of
people think it's sexist now though well
no she just doesn't like the sexist like
mentality around it where it's like
girls are weak well right but physically
physically it just was a different
there's not a muscle that you can get as
a you know like titties like even though
it's small yeah I can always tell yeah
secretive like I know some of that ctv's
I might salivate I'm like titties around
its dome sometimes I can smell
ladies area they're bigger than a stand
I can for somebody's like just since
that see like a [ __ ] honey law little
tiny nipples oh yeah like sometimes with
Pam boobs they got some big hefty areola
it's always Tara I can obviously say
like he just needs to lose weight oh
yeah like big Lance can you imagine he's
got the face ache oh my god what's going
on so I just her a way of saying like
yeah was a girl and you got beat by a
girl kinda yeah she did mention that
whenever her opponents would come up
that she would try to say it like not
like almost no words because they didn't
want she was trying to hide her her
gender as much as possible so she didn't
want to use her voice and then they
might pick up on it that's what she
would like tape her boobs like shave she
didn't like being told you're good for a
girl where'd I get that I understand I
get that should all time on stream
especially like yeah I mean female
comedians get it all the time I was like
yeah she's my favorite female comedian
it's like jokes are jokes
I never when I bring it up comedians I
never say he's next young lady you're
gonna love her I always say this next
comic and you don't know she's a lady
until I bring her on stage just so it
does it like change the image of
people's hair because people will like
change the change the image when they
know that it's a female comic I like
comedy piece right if you funny you're
funny maybe not I'm like it's I just
like knowing who's coming though so like
for me like when I was hosting I was
hosting a show and I would introduce
them as laughs dresses and that way
people before they come out they know I
mean like to be fair about i i i played
with gina for the first time like maybe
a year ago we were playing apex and i
mean like she was insane my first
thought I was like wow she's amazing for
a woman yeah we're not for a girl that's
that's not a compliment
is that because she was up like I think
they could be looked at as like women
typically don't play that that type of
game might be like a shoot-'em-up game
game called apex legends yeah I think so
dominated industry I get it but but this
one's physical like I feel like that's
the only time where it should be
separate you know like what it's comedy
gaming like you're using your fingers we
all got the same things in your mind
using fingers it's interesting because
in eSports there are no female pro
players really and anytime that they've
tried to put female pro players on a
team or create a hole that's weird
doesn't it hasn't done well that we're
you know it's also it's also because
like sometimes in and it sucks but like
gender-wise sometimes we play to our
strengths and like women we are like
emotional like mental gymnast whereas
guys sometimes are just like they can't
get out of this but they're very like
objective and fact-based which is why
they're fantastic with like athletics or
video games and things like that
I'm not fact-based you Larry don't call
me fact-based yeah based oh thank you -
yeah like with boxing it's very much
like oh they turn this way you know
badge me yeah very strategic very like
that's a lot of it - it's not just the
physiological part of it I don't know
it's it yeah that's an interesting
argument cuz like I would like to see I
know a lot of women that use a lot of
that side of their brain the more
analytical fact-based side rather than
the emotional but I the gender thing yes
it's both right there is emotional guys
as emotional girls there's very
technical people on both sides but but
physically is different it's just really
different - what argument I would meet
anyway like guys are generally better
than girls at certain sports especially
if they're both working hard on it dude
have you seen on tick-tock that
challenge where like guys can't pick up
a chair but girls can know oh my god I
want to deal with you so that's so like
okay so they have a you you have a girl
and she like puts her head on the wall
like this and you take two steps back
and then she put a chair underneath her
and she pulls it to her chest and then
stands right it up guys can't
do it what does they can't do wine I
don't know but it just shows that our
bodies are built differently do we test
this it's a loophole like a chair these
chairs way it that was the challenge you
heavy Oh like that like that chair would
work for that stool how does that work
though like what's happening that's
getting my try yeah absolutely so you
get against the wall and then you go two
steps back so one two and then you put
your head against the wall okay put the
chair in oh yeah and then you put the
chair in Oh came up with this [ __ ] I
don't even find this finally turn it to
the side so that and then guys can't do
that [ __ ] guys can't do it come on to
here and I'll do it if it's based on
like the no gravity girl so it's so
David alright the wall looks stupid
right yeah and then yep and then line up
and then put your other you got this to
here for all men everywhere that's
sports go down lower 90-degree angle go
down lower lower pull it to your chest
okay now stand up
[Applause]
sorry hold on one second see here come
into the camera here can we get a post
interview what happened there what
happened in the game I don't
I got paralyzed you got paralyzed first
of all ever said it was a lot of
pressure on my hand I'll try not to mess
up my hair but [ __ ] I'd like I got it
here and my body was like this is it we
could win ladies clothing company that's
bothering you that you want to destroy
the reputation of it yeah man whatever
Steve is wearing right now is my
favorite company now what part of your
body do you feel like was paralyzed for
this because we can't really wrap her
hand around what I just couldn't what
you guys are pinning this just isn't
possible let's find out if Steve lemo
green we're doing sports correspondents
Bo's was having trouble eating his feet
in the about the future in the chest is
where does [ __ ] I can't explain penis
between your legs that's why you can do
it that's cuz I'm grounded yes well tune
in for the next episode to see if Steve
can finally get it will he will not but
he'll tune it I don't believe it and you
just oh my god oh my god I can't get up
I can't okay it's real life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]